sich türmen der arbeit ständig auf abruf
bis vor einem jahr arbeitet mark
brandner als unternehmensberater und it-
controller für internationale firmen
er ist unterwegs in der ganzen welt
arbeitet 60 bis 70 wochenstunden er
genießt es sich immer bereit zu zeigen
für noch mehr leistung bei der firma
bekommt ja auch ab und zu mal auf die
schulter klopfen clique gewisse
wertschätzung zurück die allerdings
keine richtige wertschätzung ist das ist
eine absolute fehleinschätzung es ging
immer darum weiter weiter weiter fertig
machen mach brandner muss immer mehr
umsatz für kunden und die firma bringen
dieser hohe druck und die angst dabei zu
versagen lassen ihn rund um die uhr
arbeiten
anzeichen von erschöpfung ignoriert er
bis er eines tages buchstäblich nicht
mehr kann
immer wenn etwas neues kam habe ich dazu
ja und amen gesagt ja kann ich auch noch
machen ja kann ich noch machen kann ich
noch machen und habe die sachen aber
nicht mehr gemacht ich habe es von a
nach b gelegt ich hab dann wieder eine
excel-tabelle geöffnet und ich wusste
was mein job war ich musste was ich zu
tun hatte und ich wusste auch fachlich
in welche richtung das geht aber ich
habe gemerkt ich mache nichts mehr
dann habe ich das wieder weggelegt und
habe das nächste wieder geöffnet aber
ich saß zu dem zeitpunkt vom rechner und
das ist einfach nichts mehr passiert der
heute 33-jährige findet keine erholung
und hat immer weniger antrieb er sucht
sich ärztliche hilfe
die diagnose eine mittelschwere
depression hervorgerufen durch eine tief
greifende erschöpfung mazda adli ist
chefarzt der flieger klinik in berlin
die sich unter anderem auf die
behandlung psychosomatischer
erkrankungen spezialisiert hat häufige
ursache burn out also die meisten klagen
über psychische und körperliche
erschöpft haid gepaart mit der
unfähigkeit sich zu erholen es ist dann
quasi nicht mehr möglich den akku wieder
aufzuladen und was uns aufmerken lässt
als ärzte ist dass die zahlen in den
letzten jahren ansteigen
das spiegelt sich wider in der anzahl
der fehltage
eine untersuchung hat ergeben auf 1.000
mitarbeiter kamen in deutschland im jahr
2006 20 fehltage im jahr 2016 waren es
bereits 110
dabei kann das gefühl völlig ausgebrannt
zu sein jeden treffen ob als pfleger
dienstleister oder vorstandsvorsitzender
und wir wissen auch menschen die
aufgrund von seelischen ursachen krank
werden haben dann auch noch besonders
lange ausfall perioden und das ist
natürlich etwas was nicht nur für den
einzelnen und für die angehörigen
belastend ist sondern auch für die
volkswirtschaft eine studie der whu
prognostizierten verlust von rund 50
millionen arbeitsjahren weltweit
aufgrund psychischer leiden
das entspreche einem wirtschaftlichen
schaden von rund einer billion dollar
pro jahr bis zum jahr 2030
die lösung geld investieren in
prävention und behandlung denn laut
studie verringert jeder dollar die
ausfallkosten und führe zu einer höheren
arbeitsproduktivität im wert von 4
dollar
sechs monate war marc brandner in
behandlung ohne sie wäre er vermutlich
über jahre ausgefallen nach seiner
therapie versucht er wieder in seinem
alten job fuß zu fassen
doch diese verdichtete welt passt nicht
mehr zu ihm
er wagt stattdessen eine kehrtwende um
180 grad macht sein hobby zum beruf
ganz saubere trennung und arbeite jetzt
im prinzip als segellehrer und als
skipper bin viel im mittelmeer unterwegs
und geld ja keine frage deutlich weniger
geld viel viel weniger geld weniger als
die hälfte ist aber es ist egal
es hat den stellenwert zu bisschen
verloren weil festgestellt habe das
macht halt nicht glücklich
[Musik]